اولا احب اعرفكم نفسي انا اسمي محمود
خالد انا طالب بكليه حقوق انجلش اكتشفت
الموهبه دي من عندي حوالي سنه بالظبط اللي
هي البيت بوكس البيت بوكس اللي هو
المؤثرات الصوتيه بس عن طريق الانسان اوكي
يعني كل تسمعوه ده طالع مني
انا
[تصفيق]
اوكي اوكي
تست نسمع
ديسكو
اوكي
[موسيقى]
ش
oke
v
شكرا
حلو طبعا الناس اللي بيعمل بوكس بيعملوه
من الفم انا النهارده هعمل حاجه غريبه
شويه انا هعمله من
هنا حاجه حلوه
صحه بس من هنا وهنا مافيش حته
تاني
عجبتكم اوكي اوكي ماشي
يلا
[موسيقى]
hell
انا بس عايز اقول حاجه ان ربنا سبحانه
وتعالى اعطى كل شخص فينا
موهبه الغرض منه ان هو يفرح بيه قدامه انا
ببقى في قمه ساعتي لما اجي اعمل حاجه في
ناس مش فاهماها يعني في واحد بيقوللي انت
بتطفي من بقك قلتله يا باشا في بجد ناس
كده كفايه بس ان انا افرح الناس مش مهم
تكون الموهبه بيت بوكس اي حاجه والدكتور
اول دكتور طلع يتكلم فعلا انا نفسي ف
بالضبط انا بذاكر وممتاز ما شاء الله كويس
والله جايب في تانيه ثانوي
75% والله بجد وفي ثالثه سانوي جايب
75% مجموع السنتين 75% دخلت ح انجلش س اول
سنه الحمد
لله لما سلت فعلا حسيت ان انا قلت انا
خلاص مستقبلي ضع وبعدين قلت لا انا حط امل
في دماغي الحمد لله نجحت في اولى انا كنت
ساقط على اربع مواد يعني عادي استن على
اربع مواد الحمد لله قلت لازم يبقى عندي
امل جحت في مادتين وشلت
مادتين ف دخلت تانيه الحمد لله ولسه شايل
مادتين امتحان ال5 ف انا بتوكل على الله
بس فعلا زي ما الدكتور ما تخليش اي حاجه
توقفك لان ان شاء الله لو كل الابواب
اتقفلت هتلاقي ربنا سبحانه وتعالى بيفتحلك
بب انت ما تعرفش وتفتح ازاي فحطوا ام في
ربنا كبير دايما مهما كان
اوي في برض بيت سمعكم حلو قوي
انت مستمتع سحك بتعمل كده الله جمده والله
جم
شكرا
شكرا انا كنت بقول ايه
اه
حلوه
معلش خلاص تعبنا بقى
اوكي نسمع ايه كمان نسمع ايه كمان عايزين
تسمعوا
ايه حاجه لايه حاجه للشاب
خالد الست اشتغل الست اعمل بيت بوكس الست
ازاي طب استني كده
نجرب
اه اوكي
ثان انت بت انا عارف والله انا عارف
اوي في مفاجاه ليكم اول حاجه انتوا
مستمتعين يا جماعه بجد بج البنات اه عشان
دي انا عارف والله العظيم عارف وفي شباب
ايه عمخ ده عم البنات
بتحب اوكي
اه بمناسبه بطوط صوت دونك انا اول مره في
حياتي ا صوت دونك كنا بنتفرج على كرتون
بطوط فبا بيقولي محمود الصوت فموت رجلي
الصغير انت عارفين
فحت
معلش في مفاجاه انت فرحانه انت مش كتيه
بتقول شحل ماشي ماشي اوكي المفاجاه لكم ان
دايما اللي بيعمل البيت بوكس بتلاقيه طالع
لوحده
[موسيقى]
صح حلو طيب ايه رايكم لو شفتوا تي بيعمل
بيت بوكس اربعه بيعملوا بيت بوكس في نفس
الوقت نحي اصحابنا وهم جايين اطلعوا معان
اطلعوا
معان
اوكي نعي بيت
بوكس كريم بيت
بوكس ايوه شفت ققول لك ايوه
طبعا موري بيت
بوكس لمعلوماتكم لو لاحظتوا اللوجو ده
بسيط بتاع سبونش
صح اقسم بالله بسيط هو بسيط بياكل زيه مش
مهم مش بيت اوكي البيت ده مفاجاه ليكم
وهديه لكم يلا جاهزين اوكي 3 ت 1
[موسيقى]
come
oh
الله ايو الله
عليك شكرا لكم يا جماعه خلينا نكمل معكم
دي اول مره ل في بيسوف يا رب تكونوا
مستمتعين و شكرا لكم انكم حضرت الشب يا رب
تستمتعوا معهم
شكرا الف شكر ليك يا
[تصفيق]
اكس ت الف شكر ليك يا
اكس اول حاجه البيت بوكس المفروض ده فن
يعني كلنا تلقائي كده ابتدينا نشتغل فيه
عشان كله
يتاكد الصوت احنا بنطلعه مافيش ديجي شغال
مفيش اي من بره منون سيستم تمام يا اريت
البيت اللي احنا هقدمه دلوقتي
[موسيقى]
يعجب
for my style smiley
[تصفيق]
beatbox l f rob
st
l
m
يلا واحده تانيه حد بيقول عايز حاجه يسمع
حاجه للست مين اللي كان عايز يسمع
حاجه
k
pu
v
اخر حاجه قبل ما نودعكم يا جماعه البيت
الا اكس حرقه يعني كتر خيرك يا
اكس بتاع السيدي
يلا
x
[تصفيق]
x
ه